hello everyone and welcome back to the
chest 24 legends of chess tournament
with
the most anticipated match of the event
magnus carlsen world champion versus
vasily vanciuk every world champion's
worst nightmare
uh as kasparov once said you never know
which uh chokie will show up
at the one where he just you know
tumbles around and you know
moves pieces or the one who is
unstoppable and will crush you
so always an interesting match up uh
it's magnus with the white pieces this
is the game one and already quite a
thriller uh so let's check it out and if
you're wondering about the title is
something
rustam kasim jhanov said during the live
coverage that the
the these two uh control 800 of all the
chess talent in the world
uh that doesn't really make sense but he
just wanted i guess he just wanted to
make it sound that
that both of them are incredibly uh you
know talented
so uh let's check it out magnus with the
white pieces opens with d4
now we have knight to f6 c4 uh we have
e6 knight to f3 and the bishop to be for
with
check uh vasily goes for the
uh for the bogo indian defense and uh
also it's something that a lot of people
say when playing against ivan
it's best not to prepare as he
plays absolutely everything and it makes
no sense to prepare for him
uh best to just take take a nice walk
before before the the game or the match
so uh bishop d2 is the most common reply
here magnus goes for knight b to d2 the
groomfield variation of the bogo indian
uh we have castles uh and a3 now asking
the bishop to
either capture the knight or to move
away so bishop to e7 and now e4 magnus
grabs the center with d6
and now bishop to e2 uh we have knight f
to d7
uh and here uh magnus uh all of his
pieces are
very nicely coordinated except this
knight here so he just brings it back to
b1 he wants to shift it back to c3
from where it will be developed to a
natural square
we have d5 and now knight to c3 just
continuing development uh captures
captures and
now there is one game in the database
where b6 was played but here
we have knight back to f6 again just
challenging this knight
and it is uh as of move tended we have a
completely new game
so let's see how magnus deals with it we
have queen to c2
uh developing while defending the knight
on e4 knight beat the d7 now and
knight eat the g5 and now there's
already a lot of pressure here if this
knight moves queen captures and h7 will
be checkmate
so you have to be very careful what you
do here uh
we have c5 by choki uh and now bishop to
e3
just continuing development still not
deciding whether to castle queenside or
kingside and here
uh vasily took some two and a half
minutes to decide what to do on his next
move
uh and he decided for queen to a5 check
he basically wants to play queen to c7
but this way with playing queen to a5 he
could some
he could maybe get magnus to move back
his bishop and then play queen to c7
resulting in this bishop now being uh
developed to a lesser square for example
uh also there is the possibility after
this queen a5 check to just go b4
let's say and after captures bishop d2
but that requires
too much uh calculation and it could it
couldn't uh
could be not all that great so instead
after queen a5 check magnus just goes
king to f1 basically saying that
i'm not interested in castling i just
want to attack on the king side and
seeing a move like this usually means
that if you play something like h6h4 is
definitely coming because this knight
can never be captured if you capture
then again
this knight falls as there will again be
checkmate on h7 if it moves
so it's not really a peace sacrifice so
after king f1 we have
queen back to c7 uh and now uh rook to
d1 and here the situation on the clock
is eight minutes magnus six minutes
for choki uh and uh
what do you do here uh you could uh you
could do a lot of things
uh but b6 is the most natural developing
move you want to place the bishop to
this long diagonal and
bring the rook into the game so here we
have knight to e5 by magnus a very
interesting pawn sacrifice you could
also just push d5 for example
and get a nice pass the d-pawn but for
some reason magnus doesn't
doesn't like this instead magnus went
for knight to e5
and this is the the beginning of uh uh
well just a
very straightforward attack on uh
black's king's side
so here uh it's upon sacrifice uh and
vasily accepts the challenge
knight capture spawn captures queen
captures and now bishop to f3
challenging the rook here uh we have
rooked a b8 and
now the immediate h4 maybe g3 and then
h4 as it also just
threatens uh to pick up the queen but uh
black can just always go back and visual
f4 e5 is extremely strong here
so magnus uh completely disregards this
he goes h4 he wants to play uh now
rookie street the g3 and
bring another attacker into the game so
queen back to c7 now you don't have to
worry about stuff like that and you can
also
start with e5 uh maybe this bishop can
now also be used
on this diagonal uh rook h3
uh and now just bishop to b7 uh instead
going after this uh light square bishop
here we have rooked the e1 by magnus and
now
rook beat the d8 and here uh black is
doing uh
black is doing very well uh white is the
one who's attacking but black is up upon
and
his position is is great however the
problem for vasily is that
he has only one and a half minute on the
clock and the magnus says five minutes
but okay
you do you do get a 10 second increment
for every move you make
so here we have bishop captures and b7
by magnus queen captures and the bishop
back to d2 now magnus wants to shift the
bishop over to this
diagonal to help out with the attack on
the black king the rook is coming to g3
and so on so h6 challenging this knight
and just bishop to c3
again the knight is off limit since
again
you will pick up the knight on f6 and
then you are also probably getting
checkmated
so after this bishop the c3 move we have
rook f28
uh just making room for the king if
needed and now
king to g1 uh getting th the king
to a safer square and here uh the
problem is
uh magnus probably didn't want to play
king to g1 he spent a lot of time here
he had uh he was uh
up on the clock a lot and here he spent
like four minutes even more than four
minutes and he caught up the chooky on
time uh problem is he
probably wanted to play knight captures
on f7 it's really really a complicated
move
but uh i don't think it was enough time
to calculate or maybe
he was able to calculate that it doesn't
give him all that much point is that
after king captures in rook g3
you want to go here and deliver
checkmate so rook g8 defends this now
queen g6
check king to f8 and now let's say you
go after this e6 pawn
it's impossible to you know probably
calculate this all the way
uh for example rook d1 check the kink
has to come into the game and now rook
d6
adds more uh defense to the f6 knight
and now let's say if rook captures
bishop captures
uh and now bishop captures an f6 problem
is black doesn't capture here but rather
captures the rook and now
you don't have anything captures
captures and captures followed by rook
f7 blocking black is up a whole rook
and without without much issues so this
is what carlson was calculating and he
spent
almost all of his time here so in the
end he went king to g1
but still he he is better on time and
now rook d7 now black just wants to
double up here on the d
file knight back to f3 now shifting the
knight over to e5 as the rook is on d7
and bishop to d6
uh awaiting 95 and preparing to capture
so
magnus goes for it and the bishop
captures an e5 with bishop captures
that's not a bishop and rook e to d8 now
doubling up on the d
file could be could be very dangerous
uh and here uh just bishop back to c3
magnus doesn't like
to open up the the g file even with rook
g3 the king can just move and it's
not a problem there there is no good way
to continue the attack
uh and the black blacks attack is is
coming much much sooner
so instead magnus keeps the bishop
bishop to c3
it is much stronger than this knight so
you do want to keep it in the game
and now queen back to c7 hoping to get
the queen over to f4
to to to basically activate the queen
so queen c1 magnus defends this and now
uh by playing queen to c1 magnus allowed
a really beautiful move uh which uh
i didn't think uh uh i didn't think
vasily would play it as he had like 10
seconds on the clock here
uh and he found it he played knight to
e4 and with this knight to e4 move what
uh what he did
is that he ensures the elimination of
the dark square bishop and with this
dark square bishop out of the way
magnus really doesn't have any
compensation for the sacrificed pawn
and of course you cannot go for the rook
because just rook d1 check wins the
queen and that's uh that's just game or
or even rather
uh you can't even capture here uh
because well the queen covers this it
would be checkmate so
you have to play some like rook to e1
and then just throw captures on c1 it
gets the job done so uh after this
knight to the e4
we have rooked the f3 by magnus and now
knight captures on c3
queen captures on c3 and now rook d4
without the presence of this dark square
bishop on this diagonal
uh the rooks are now free to roam the
board so rook d4
uh now completely pretty much blocks the
queen out of the game
g3 and now rook eight to d7 just uh
getting uh the rook to a much uh much
more active square
uh keeping control of f7 and so on next
to get activated is the queen so b3 by
magnus
defending the c4 pawn so the queen can
now move and the queen to c6 now
pressuring the rook here
rook f2 e3 and now a5
with a4 by magnus and the queen to d6
now
now uh black knight decides that uh i
trade off some of the rooks we have
queen to c2
and now queen to c6 uh here both black
and white are making some very safe
moves to get
that 10 second increment on the clock as
they want to get up to a minute and
something so they can start
creating some plans so here we have
queen e2
and we have rook uh 7 to d6 queen to h5
by magnus and
now queen to d7 uh the aliajin's gun is
now
activated we have queen back to f3 uh
and
queen to d8 so again just making little
moves to gain a time
king h2 and now rook to d2 we have rook
one to e2 by magnus he doesn't want to
allow this rook to come to b2 and then
the other rook to land on d2 and here
uh black manages to trade off a pair of
rooks so queen captures
and now rook to d2 now putting pressure
on the queen on the f2 pawn rook to b3
will be an idea
at some point uh so queen e1 and now
h5 just grabbing more space at some
point you want to activate the king and
start
pushing those central pawns so rook to
f3 and now
g6 we have queen to e4
activating the queen uh also uh instead
of this g6 queen to d4 was also a
possibility to grab hold of this
important central square put pressure on
f2 uh this way by playing j
uh g6 magnus activates his queen on a
very nice central square
but rook d4 uh vasil immediately uh
kicks it away queen b7
and now rook to d7 pushing the queen
back queen to c6 and now
king g7 we have king to g2 and
now rook to d6 pushing the queen back we
have queen to b7 and now queen d7
uh black offers a queen trade and uh
white white should not trade black has
too many too many weaknesses and it's uh
it's only
uh black is only down one pawn which
usually you can hold in a
uh king and rook end game but here
magnus does not like his chances
there's the the b3 pawn is extremely
weak and once you start pushing these
pawns it's just going to be very very
hard to hold
so queen back to e4 and now f6
f6 has has been played next is coming e5
f5 and so on
so rook to e3 putting pressure on the e6
pawn and now just
e5 we have king h2 by magnus and
now comes rook to d2 queen to f5 was
also very interesting here as it forces
a queen trade since the f2 pawn is under
attack
uh but uh vasily decides to leave it the
queen's on the board for now he plays
the
rook
here attacks the pawn and prepares maybe
rook b2 to go after the b3 pawn
so rook e2 blocking and now rook back to
d4
we have queen to a8 uh and now rook to
d3 now the b
three point is under attack and magnus
is forced into passivity
uh with rook to beat you could also play
rook to e3 but
uh it's hard to say do you want to make
three pawn islands or or maybe uh
it's hard to say so magnus instead goes
rook to b2 defends the b3 pawn this way
but now
f5 now with the rook out of the way you
are free to expand at will here
queen to b8 putting pressure on the e5
pawn and now just queen d6 defending
while also offering a queen trade so
queen b7 with check
king h6 and the now queen to c8 hoping
to get some
queen to h8 checkmate action going on as
uh the pawn here covers the g5 square so
you have to be very careful
uh vasily blocks this with queen to f6
and now comes queen to c7
uh just playing something not not much
to go for here
and now f4 uh problem is that uh next uh
this is coming and
the rook will be under attack so magnus
immediately moves the rook to e2
now with a double attack on the pawn
here but now captures with
check f captures and now e4 saying uh
you cannot capture this pawn and e3 is
coming because if you do
well then just rook d2 check followed by
a nice queen to f
uh queen to f1 checkmate uh the pawn
covers the the g4 square so instead we
have queen to b8
again keeping an eye on the square
hoping that chucky moves the queen
uh so he can deliver checkmate but now
rook
captures on b3 rook here was also an
option uh followed by rook f2 check
uh but uh vasily says we're just going
to capture this and maybe then go
go for something like this so queen to
e8 now
going after the rook and here uh we have
this e3 move by black
uh there was also the extremely
interesting rook captures on g3
point is that the rook cannot be
captured because this check
forces the king to the second rank and
after this this is captured with check
and you have all the time in the world
to win the game with black as white will
not get his chance to deliver checkmate
but instead we have e3
uh and now comes king to g2 so magnus
gets the king to a little bit of a safer
square
and now rook to c3 here it's not
clear how to continue the game properly
for black
queen d4 for example if queen d4
guarding the pawn then white can't
deliver queen of fate
check and then you have to go back with
queen to g7 so instead
uh black sacrifices the pawn with rook
to d3
uh sorry with rook to c3 and magnus
immediately captures it
rook captures an e3 now rook captures on
c4 and now rook
f3 so you cannot uh uh cannot move
the queen away from the defense of the
h8 square as then queen to h8 is coming
and this is checkmate
so here uh the problem is uh you have to
you have to play something like rook to
c to check and start checking the white
king uh however
uh vasily played queen to g7 and now uh
it's actually
game over for for uh for poor chucky
uh but feel free to pause the video and
try to find the win for magnus here
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting either
rook to f7 or even more straightforward
rook to a fade because
this will just be a game over uh the
king has nowhere to go
and uh well after this you're you're
just getting checkmated for example if
this check comes you can just go king h3
there's nothing to
continue here and the rook to h8 is
coming that's that's game over
however magnus misses this and magnus
plays queen to e3 check
incredible as it is king to h7 and
now queen to e6 by magnus uh
just uh attacking the the rook here on
c4
uh we have rook to c2 with check uh also
uh sorry rook to c2 with check if you
try something like queen to d for now
uh then uh queen to f7 check aking to h6
queen to f8 second king to g7 so this
will hold for black so instead uh we
have rook the c2 check
we have now king to h3 and now king to
h6
again very very unpleasant for black
magnus goes queen to e3 check king h7
and now of course
uh queen to e8 again there is this
possibility of
rook to f8 on the next move uh and uh
there is no way to stop it
uh chucky plays king to h6 and now rook
to f8 again the
same the same idea wins the game but
magnus again misses it magnus plays
queen to e3 check again uh we have king
to h7 and now
magnus obviously didn't want to repeat
the position as he wanted to win the
game
now but he played queen to b3 now with
a double attack here but there also is a
problem
uh it's not just a double attack it's
also this this
and rook here is the idea but now the
game is completely lost for magnus so
feel free to pause the video and win
this game for vasily while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
unstoppable mate and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
it's queen to d7 check and it was in
this position on move 74 that magnus
carlsen resigned the game
and here you see why vasily van chuk is
every world champion's worst nightmare
point is that the king has nowhere to go
and once you play g4 it's just queen
captures and g for checkmate and that is
it
so really really incredible stuff uh uh
vasily was better for the entire game
magnus
sacrificed this this spawn for sort of a
caveman approach uh
attacking maneuver uh but vasily
defended well and then he was just
better for the entire time but
then the the clock situation stepped in
and then magnus was better and then
he had a completely winning position uh
but in the end uh
uh chuki is the the one who emerged
victorious
so quite a thriller already in round one
i can't wait to wait to see what happens
next uh so
let's uh check it out and enjoy that as
well
i would like to thank ben edwards uh
adam geffert uh henrik hawkinson
uh tom uh uh hathorn uh
heythorntheweight
and the rayner gibbons for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the magnus invitational
not magnus invitational the chesmar for
legends of chess uh checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your saturday